my brother is
an absolute genius he is yeah like i
know i'm smart
but there's a difference there's there's
smart like i'm able to figure [ __ ] out
and i'm able to watch somebody do
something and i can repeat it
fast and quick like i'm a fast learner
my brother
is comes up with the origin he just
comes up with the original ideas
innovator he's the innovator he he just
thinks outside the box he's just got
this brilliance about
him that allows him to just to come up
with these ideas that that
you would never even the angle that you
would just never think of
would be the first thing that he thinks
of is this is the
is the is his brilliance yeah so we
wrote the outline i wrote the whole
outline
after i wrote the outline i started
writing the whole book he got out
and i wrote the whole book just with
emails
emails between me me and john and phone
calls
and then of course he disappeared which
likes at the end of the book he
disappears
i went back to prison but what happened
is this
um what i was going to say was when i
put up
when i did the i po i put up the um i
had a website
while i was still in prison and i put up
the um the story
so i actually put up his story on my
website just prior to getting out of
prison maybe a year or two in or year or
two before i got out
i put up the story and i had like photos
and stuff
on it i had his brother's mug shot on it
his brother contacted me and was like
hey um you know you know um
[ __ ] what's your brother's name
christopher yeah christopher yeah this
is you know chris
uh chris boziak i'm john uh john's
brother
uh when people run my name your story
comes up
and it's causing me major [ __ ]
problems i need you to remove my story
and remove my uh my name and i went so
of course i'm emailing him back
and we're we're going through somebody
by the way so i can't email him really
directly
i'm actually emailing him through this
chick named joy that was helping me
so i email i shoot one to her she shoots
one back i show that either yeah i
didn't know that either
we're going back and forth and he starts
saying look i need to remove this
my name from it i went okay well
well i said okay that would make i have
to go through rewrite the whole thing
have joy i gotta pay to have this done
joy's not you know people
this costs money and time and say well
what are you going to do for me
he's like what do you mean well i need
some pictures you know your brother's
disappeared
i said i know where he is i'm writing
letters the freedom of information act
i'm trying to figure out where he is
um and i end up saying i need i need
some photos some childhood photos some
this and i start asking him questions
he's like
what he goes well i got those photos but
that would require me
to deal with my mother which i'm
unwilling to do
he didn't want to go there he said had
to go to your moms he had to go in the
basement he had to dig out the
whatever you dig out the files yeah i
don't want to have to deal with her
i don't have to explain the whole
situation i don't want to do that
and i went okay well then i'm not taking
your name off the thing well it's
causing me major problems i said well
bro there's multiple articles out there
on you being arrested for credit card
fraud
so don't tell me that my story is
upsetting
is causing you problems when there's
multiple you've got
multiple arrests you've been imprisoned
in multiple multiple states
you've got multiple articles about you
being arrested for credit card fraud so
my story is not affecting you
the problem is my story tells the entire
cohesive story
as opposed to a random article here and
there and i'm sure he didn't like that
and my
i had the photograph photographs public
records so we go back and forth back and
forth and he basically was unwilling to
do anything other than to say
take this down no i'm not gonna [ __ ]
take it down i'll change it i'll alter
it
i'll use a different name but give me
something make it worth my while in some
way
he wouldn't do it so so anyway that's
why when you missed your brother i
just wrote i just remembered thinking
yeah it's right
up until this point me and my brother
have been pretty tight where's your
brother now
i believe he's in texas he lives in
texas okay and he don't you don't talk
to him no
this up until this point me and my
brother have been really close like we
grew up together
you know obviously and um you know when
i was in prison he was like the only one
that was there for me sending me money
and like taking care of me and [ __ ]
and now you won't even speak to me why
won't he speak to you
obviously he's pretty upset about him me
involving him and this whole the book
and and all that and which means i get
it dude i get it
you know what i mean i get it you know
you're trying to live the straight and
narrow and you're trying to
and i believe i don't think he even told
his wife doesn't even know i don't think
she really knew
like everything you know what i mean
like i kind of think he might have
minimized or whatever when he was
you know explaining everything to his
wife and i kind of just peeled open a
whole [ __ ] can of worms
yeah you know what i mean i get it and
i'm not even like
i'm kind of hurt by it but at the same
time dude i get it we're adults and
you know you guys got to live his life
so so if your brother was the genius and
your brother was the innovator behind
all this stuff why did
so did you rise higher in the ranks than
he did or did you accomplish more make
more than he did or was he you know
for him it was never about that he
wasn't like i
i he was just [ __ ] around with it as
a joke
karting i know that's whatever but he
was just [ __ ] around
i got [ __ ] obsessed with it and i
made it
you know what i mean my 24 7 365. you
know what i'm saying so it was never
really about like
i you know went further than him or
whatever because once he got
once he got busted um once me and him
got chased out of a
[ __ ] walmart for trying to get a
laptop i got away he got caught
really and i feel that i feel [ __ ]
horrible about it because i woke him up
explain that explain it explain like i'm
laughing about it
i'll eat you feel horrible and i'm
thinking
i'm thinking because this is what
started like my brother's
downward trajectory okay you know what i
mean it was like i
first of all he was because he was
living with me in coral springs and i
remember waking him up
this day i remember the status things i
woke him up out of a dead [ __ ] sleep
to go commit credit card fraud
because i wanted to go out and and steal
you know what i mean so i wake him up i
i make him go to walmart with me to
[ __ ] cart a laptop because i think i
think because he he had the id for the
card
so you know he had to be the one to do
it you know what i mean so
we get there we get back there we get
the laptop we get to the counter
the dude looks at the card swipes it
looks at the id
picks up the phone we got a code red
back here at electronics
i immediately knew what [ __ ] time it
was so i kind of just do an about face
and i slowly start
walking towards the front door i look
back my brother's still standing at the
counter
and i'm thinking in my head i'm like man
just [ __ ] walk away walk away walk
away
so i get to the front door to the
automatic doors in walmart they slide
open
here comes my brother just blowing past
me with two dudes chasing him just a
[ __ ] full out and
the the look of sheer [ __ ] terror on
his face
as he was going through them [ __ ]
doors in walmart and the two [ __ ]
dudes are chasing them
i'll never forget to look in that kid's
face and that's when it hit me in my
stomach i was like i [ __ ] up
and then one dude tries to grab my shirt
i luckily i i did some kind of spin move
and slapped his hand away and booked it
out of the parking lot i got away
and i went and hid in the [ __ ] woods
and he went to jail got arrested you
know what i mean
yeah i felt bad apparently his one of
his flip flaps [ __ ] blew out on him
halfway across the parking lot and they
got his ass you know what i mean
so yeah and i felt so horrible for this
you know but i stayed up all night i
didn't sleep
you know tracking him seeing what jail
he was going to i watched him go from
city to county and then i was on it you
know what i mean i was i didn't sleep
the whole night i was as soon as the
[ __ ] bill bondsman's opened in the
morning i got him a bail bondsman
he called me after his first court
appearance he's like oh i got a bond
bubble i was like listen
i already got a bondsman on the way up
there to get you you know what i mean
just sit tight and i
bonded him out i did the right thing and
then
like two or three weeks later the bail
bondsman calls me
and he's like you can come pick up your
money they drop they drop the charges or
some [ __ ]
yeah something weird happened in the
court i don't know if it was a clerical
error or what happened but they just
they weren't they weren't going to
prosecute it or whatever so i got my
bond money back
wow so we're thinking it's all good my
brother's like oh i skated on that one i
was like yeah you got lucky
well about um two or three weeks later
we get a knock on the door early in the
morning and it was one of those
so you i knew it was the police because
the police only [ __ ] knocked one way
at [ __ ] seven o'clock in the morning
you know nobody else is beating on my
door like that
so i opened up the doors coral springs
police there you know it's christopher
bosack here
and he was in the room sleep but he had
his he had his room door closed
and i was like no he's not here he's uh
he's in the cop he's like
where do where is he i was like uh he
went to michigan he took off and went to
michigan yesterday
and the cops like do you have any id so
i went and got my id gave it to him just
so he can make sure that i wasn't
christopher and he said um oh well
well good thing he did take off because
he's got a warrant out for his arrest
and i was like i told the cop i was like
i got my bond money back from that he's
like yeah well the
somebody picked up the the case and
they're there he hit so he could get a
warrant for his arrest
so i went and woke him up like dude you
know [ __ ] police were just here
looking for you he's like oh man that
was almost my freedom
and uh he took off that night and went
to michigan
and uh he got caught up in michigan like
two weeks later at a target
and that's when the whole thing unfolded
so then he
he got he got jailed up there and then
he had to get extradited back down to
florida
and the whole thing so after that whole
thing happened with him he was he was
done
like that was the end of it for him like
once he got caught
you know i mean coral springs and went
to michigan went through that whole
[ __ ] [ __ ] i think
after that he was done like he was like
you know what i'm gonna go to college
i'm gonna get a degree i'm gonna you
know
do what i gotta do so he was out of the
life of crime and pretty much
away from me at that time like after
that we went our separate ways like he
took off and
you know went and did his thing and then
i i made carding my life
after that yeah
foreign